do you know what the realm is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed tell each other over and
over till we forget that it's a lie
take what happened to You Lord virus
when you were a child
if not for your mutilation at the end of
a second-rate sorcerer you wouldn't be
helping the Lord's Chosen being his
light into the world knowledge has made
you powerful but there's still so much
you don't know what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones video today I want to talk
about Lord Varys and the main in the box
lately I have noticed a resurgence in
people's interest about this particular
part of the story I would say over the
last two weeks there have been about 10
different people asking me about the
sorcerer that cut Varys when he was a
child so I figured it was time to make a
video that way I could answer some of
the questions you might have
the main question I was seeing the most
was what ever happened to the main in
the box but another person wanted to
know why he chose to cut Varys instead
of any other little boy who might have
been living in that area but in order
for me to come up with an answer let's
go over what we've been told thus far in
my opinion Varys is one of the most
interesting characters in the story but
as we all know he is shrouded in mystery
no one really knows anything about Varys
and you can't even be sure if what we
had been told is the truth because of
the line of work Varys is in he was the
master of whisperers dating all the way
back to the mad Kings reign and his life
leading up to this position is a mystery
however Varys has told the story about
how he was mutilated as a child and it's
obvious that moment has had a big impact
on his life
you probably don't entirely trust me
don't take it personally I don't
entirely trust myself and yet I have
seen things and heard things things you
have not things I wish I had known
according to varus when he was still a
child he used to travel with a troupe of
actors around the Free Cities one day
after one of our performances
the sorcerer made an offer for me that
my master found too tempting to refuse I
feared the man meant to use me the same
way I had heard other men were using
small boys but in truth the only part of
me he had need of was my manhood
he gave me a potion that made me
powerless to move or speak yet did
nothing to dull my senses what the long
hooked blade he sliced me root and stem
chanting all the while I watched him
burn my manly parts on the brazier the
flames turned blue and I heard a voice
answer his call though I did not
understand the words they spoke the
mummer's had sailed by the time he was
done with me once I had served his
purpose the man had no further interest
in me when I asked him what I should do
now he answered that he supposed I
should die to spite him I chose to live
I begged I stole and I sold what parts
of my body I still had soon I was as
good a thief as any in mirror and when I
was older I learned that often the
contents of a man's letters are more
valuable than the contents of his purse
this is what Varys tells Tyrion in the
television show and it's almost
identical to what Varys says in the
books but there is one big difference
there is no mention of Varys ever
finding the sorcerer in the books but we
know he captured him on Game of Thrones
sorcery
hello my old friend it's been a long
time I have no doubt the revenge you
want will be yours in time if the
stomach for it
the first question I want to get to is
why did the man cut Varys based on the
story Varys told it seemed like he
wanted Varys specifically because he
made his master an offer he could not
refuse why would you pay so much for
Varys when I'm sure he could have gotten
one for a cheaper price or even free if
he just kidnapped one what is so special
about Varys well I tend to believe the
theory that Varys is actually one of the
descendents from the Blackfyre family
house Blackfyre was a direct offshoot of
House Targaryen the house was founded by
daemon Blackfyre who was the legitimized
bastard of King Aegon the fourth their
sigil was a black three-headed dragon
breathing black fire on red the
Targaryen sigil what the colors reversed
many people believe Varys could be a
descendant from this family and I happen
to think it's true ever since the
beginning of the show we have seen Varys
secretly working behind the scenes with
alario trying to put House Targaryen
back on the iron throne one hand
we need time Khal Drogo will not make
his move until his son is born delays we
fast I reply this could also explain why
Varys shaves his head he might be trying
to hide that platinum blonde hair even
black fires were known to have I also
happen to think this is why the sorcerer
chose to cut Varys over any other child
he may have came across but there are
two different ways you can look at this
you could say he noot elated his
genitals to prevent Varys from ever
furthering the bloodline one way to
prevent someone from producing an heir
other than killing them is to remove
their reproductive parts that's one
reason why I think he could have done
this but on the other hand this man was
a sorcerer and he may have needed Kings
blood to perform some kind of fire and
blood ritual we have seen Melisandre do
this with Gendry she did not cut off his
parts but she did put a leech down his
pants
Melisandre then had the blood filled
leeches thrown into the fire the mana
cut Varys took it one step further
instead of just drawing some of his
blood he turned him into a unique
instead and we all know there is great
power in King's blood some people say
the sorcerer just wanted to use the
virgin blood of a boy but I disagree
I believe Varys does come from a very
powerful family you can also just look
at the way Varys spells his name it's
very similar to Daenerys and Viserys all
of their names and what the why is the
thing about this event that I'm
interested in the most is not why Varys
was chosen by the sorcerer I want to
know who he was calling out to in the
flames whatever happened has terrified
Varys for most of his life he even says
he still dreams about that night he
doesn't dream of the sorcerer or the
action of him being cut but what keeps
Varys up at night is what the voice said
I still dream of that night not of the
sorcerer
not of his blade I dream of the voice
from the flames was it a god the demon
the conjurer's trick I don't know it
might not even be the voice of a human
because Varys isn't sure himself he says
was it a God a demon or a conjurors
trick I don't know but the sorcerer
called out in a voice answered ever
since that day Varys has hated magic and
all those who practice it I'm assuming
that whatever it was must be tied into
her lore the sorcerer performed a very
similar ritual to the one we have seen
Melisandre perform and as you all know
Kim Bora knows what the voice said it
also seems like Melisandre knows as well
because she knows Varys will die very
soon now I know she just said Varys
would die in this country meaning
Westeros but they never would have had
Melisandre say that unless it was gonna
happen soon and by soon I mean next
season but now I want to move on to the
main question everyone keeps asking and
that is whatever happened to the man in
the box if you want to know why I think
the flame turned blue and what that
means for Varys next season I will put
the link to that video down below I
don't want to go over all of that again
because I'm sure most of you watching
this video already know what I think
about all of that the first time we see
the man in the box was in season 3 Varys
and Tyrion are having a discussion about
revenge patience and influence as Varys
is prying open the box this is when
Varys finally reveals what happened to
him as a boy after Varys tells the story
to Tyrion he also tells him this is why
he wanted to help against Stannis and
Melisandre he said it was a form of
symbolic revenge on sorcerers because
Stannis had aligned himself with the red
priestess from a shy but Tyrion isn't
quite satisfied with this response
because he wants to exact revenge on the
people who have actually wronged him
however Tyrion is in for a big surprise
because that's exactly what beerus was
talking about as well this is revealed
when Varys opens up the Box you see
Varys was tellin Tyrion that sometimes
you need to be patient to have that kind
of influence and Varys says influence
can grow with patience this scene may
prove that Varys is in it for the long
game he's neither stupid or impulsive if
he needs to he can
forever but when an if he wants to
achieve something he will do just that
somehow some way but in time he too can
get his revenge this also shows just how
extensive his network of little spies is
Varys was able to find this man decades
after the fact in a place far far away
from where Varys is currently at we
never see the man in the box again after
this scene whatever did happen to the
sorcerer couldn't have been pleasant but
I am assuming it would have also had to
have been done before the end of season
4 because that's when Varys and Tyrion
both leave King's Landing for Pentos you
have to wonder did Varys used the same
exact box to escort Tyrion across the
sea it's probably not the same box
although they did look very similar
ever since Varys and Terry and left
King's Landing there has been no hints
that Varys is still keeping the man
alive so I would like to imagine Varys
tortured this man until he expired
I don't think Varys would have put him
out of his misery either not after what
he had done to Varys you have to
remember the conversation Barisan Tyrion
were having during that scene was about
revenge and patience Varys would not
have been satisfied by just simply
killing the man oh no no no no he needed
to pay for traumatizing Varys for the
remainder of his life you could see that
the sorcerer was already an old man who
didn't look like he was in the best of
shape as is he also had to keep in mind
who knows how long he had been in that
box before Varys even showed it to
Tyrion I would bet that Varys returned
the favor by mutilating the sorcerer
himself then he probably tortured him
and kept him alive at the same time for
as long as humanly possible at this
point I would say he is dead but trust
me this will not be the last time we
hear about what happened to Varys that
night this was a pivotal moment in
varus's life in a will come full circle
in the end when it comes to Varys as a
character we have been leading up to
something big we find out Varys as a
unique in season one than in season two
Varys tells Tyrion that one day he will
toe him the story about how he was cut
in season 3 Varys tells Tyrion this
haunting story then he reveals the main
in the Box in season 6 Varys meet
skinned vara and they have a
conversation about the mother of dragons
and
ulti kinvaras says as long as varus
stays loyal to Daenerys then he has
nothing to fear from her but not before
she reminds him about the most traumatic
event in his life
she tells varus that she knows what
happened that night and she knows what
the voice said from the flames in the
very next season
varus meets Melisandre and she tells him
she knows he's gonna die in the final
season all of this will come to fruition
in varus has known this ever since he
heard the voice in the flames he might
not know exactly what he heard
but he knows whatever it was wasn't
something he ever wanted to see or hear
again Varys is going to die next season
and however that happens will tie into
everything I have said in the video let
me know what you think
put all your thoughts or questions down
below in the comment section I would
love to hear what you have to say
anyways I want to thank all of you for
watching the video I really appreciate
that and I also want to thank all of my
supporters on patreon thank you all very
much
I hope you have a great day I will see
you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you